I, I'd actually like to go back to the, the, the, what we were talking about earlier, which is humility and how it relates to forgiveness
and I think that's it's possible that you and, and Professor Volf actually might differ on your, your
perspective on forgiveness
in that
we were talking about this yesterday in our section
do you need, do you need to
have first, you know,
have a apology offered to grant forgiveness, or can you
grant forgiveness without someone being willing to, to sort of
say, "Oh, I've committed an act that, you know, I need to ask forgiveness for." I mean that's, it's part of, I think.
I think I would say that the true forgiveness is not a kind of bargain in the end. You know,
I'm prepared to forgive you because you now have said you're really sorry
for being so bad,
so I'll forgive you.
You know, it's not, I mean, my experience with, with conflict situations,
it, it
has
to be something you're initiating from within yourself.
So forgiveness has such that
because, it sounds, you know,
saying, saying, I'm going to forgive you, sort
of there's an arrogance about that. Yeah, no, I understand, forgiveness implies
obviously that you believe that you have been wronged, but
I think it's
I, I use the term forgiveness
almost in the sense of
putting, putting to one side what has happened,
you know, let, let, letting, the, the, past
be there. I mean,
you know, what, what,
Miroslav was saying a moment or two ago on the, one the perpetrator, you know,
the willingness to, to recognize, I mean, I think that's all bound in, in with it as well
and, you know, we can, we can try and divide up these different emotions, I think
they, they
add together, you know, a sense of humility, a sense of forgiveness,
a sense that you're prepared to acknowledge you, you too may have done wrong.
Actually, one of the, the
most interesting moments in the Northern Ireland
process was one when I said to
actually, the, these were republicans,
you know about,
about, the Reverend Paisley, you know,
why don't you, why don't you just trust him
and, you know,
trust him, I mean, trust
him
but actually, you know, that was part
in the end of what
got it through. Now,
I think all of those emotions have to be linked in
to that, but I,
so maybe forgiveness I'm using
as a bit of a shorthand there, but,
but I think at the, at the minimum it's a willingness
to put the past behind you.